chisinau in pelle tutti ragazzi e poi
venuti questo video sono fatti j
oggi siamo in un luogo che c'è
praticamente siccome stamattina stavo
facendo le registrazioni del film quindi
vanno truccarmi hanno messo sta cosa in
faccia per sembrare che fosse in guerra
mi hanno messo questo che un giubbotto
vero militare c'è proprio una roba
assurda con tanto di foulard a che cazzo
serve sta cosa
ecco adesso sono mimetizzato ragazzi non
mi vedo neanche io non vedo un cazzo
niente ragazzi sicura ma ha vestito così
e non ci avevo voglia di togliermi la
roma ho deciso di fare blog così forte
segue prima di cominciare ripartire con
la fama della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da teo che ha
fatto sto capolavoro della madonna che
però ormai già la sporcizia in faccia
perché è questa che rende sexy un uomo
c'era perché che io la fan arte per
farvela vedere la metto in montaggio
video no e siccome ogni tanto mi capita
di fare degli errori montaggio video
perché sono un essere umano sporco ma lo
sono nello scorso vlog visto dimenticato
di mettere la fan art
e stato bellissimo perché la scena è
stata questa la chiave con la farà da
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da maria che ha fatto ma chi è
bella questa fanart pharma proprio bella
casa sembra vera non c'e limite alla mia
idiozia
avevate dei dubbi come se ragazzini che
possiamo passare a linux ico emotive
mino stanno scrivendo favi ma quanto
tempo sarà il marocco visto che ho
cambiato sfondo ormai da un po ci sarò
ancora per una settimana e poi torno a
milano che rimarrò a milano per una
settimana circa dopodiché ragazzi sto
via ancora cinque giorni a los angeles
perché dobbiamo fare delle riprese del
film anche lì e sapete che cosa
significa los angeles vero altro blog è
fico in arrivo detto questo ragazzi
siccome so che molti di voi mi
scriveranno ma favi ma come cazzo fai a
stare sotto questa roba che ci sono 400
gradi mi sto fatto tamente squagliando
porca [ __ ] siamo passati all'evento
della settimana che è ancora più figo la
mia stima
succedono cose troppo figo non so perché
questo sentiva ragazzi ho fatto ben due
cose strane alquanto strane sono andato
a visitare la città di fango che è una
delle location dove è stato girato il
gladiatore famoso film con l'attore con
me con me sono io che recito che ho
fatto tipo
se epica quindi vi lascio al video si
sono non dovrei esordire così perché
sembra un minchione sono a new york
quello è un grattacielo siamo a dove
hanno girato il gladiatore per la mente
qual è la 5 quella questa è la città del
fango e si chiama così è praticamente
per arrivarci bisogna attraversare il
fiume su dei sacchi sul fiume
devo stare sui sacchi per arrivare
dall'altra parte c'è il roba che se
mente un piede ma le vado giù
spero che non succeda perché il telefono
in mano e potrebbe essere un problema
ho voluto coinvolgervi in questa
avventura incredibile non so se ce la
farò è una cosa tipo sembra un videogame
solo che non c'è il respons ok alla
piano d'anna vacca
secondo me io non so quante persone sono
morte a facendo sta cosa non ne ho idea
quasi a che fai ma io passi tout va a
grazie fratello un grande bene qua yeah
ok dio mio come frate scontati mi metti
nello zaino mi metti un anno noti a
tutti non mi toccare il pene per favore
[Musica]
sei un killer stava buttando giù mi
stava buttando giù ragazzo e lui è il
killer cosa fa lo stimo sì sì sì sì sì
sono vivo sono fottutamente vino non so
come e siccome esperienza nei videogames
più o meno so che ci saranno pokémon
rari che se hai scassato il muro
adesso accade tutto nel dio e mezz'ora
che sto salendo non ci sto più facendo
sono miliardo di fottuti scalini
skrillex da posto
[Musica]
banking potuto iscriversi ma quanto
spacca quel bambino da 1 a 227 dopodiché
ragazzi mi hanno fatto anche provare a
sparare siccome nel film usiamo anche
delle armi vere ho avuto della ca ga
parecchia mi sono fatto riprendere nel
mentre va beh vi lascio anche qui al
video che si scavi
[Musica]
io sono diventato un killer fa chi è la
faccia sporca fa un po killer casa cioè
come se andate a buttare la testa
nell'immondizia poi uscite così se siete
dei killer vento queste ragazzine che
possiamo forse fa vi risponde sono tutto
gasato di farlo perché non vedo l'ora
d'italia mista verda la prima domanda
arriva da to add on che bel nome poi
risponde fatima quanto cazzo sei alto
moltissimi si stupiscono della mia
altezza perché poi sono altro tipo un
metro e 81 o non lo so e molte quando
magari mi vedono dal vivo dicono minchia
quanto cazzo sei alto ma perché i
ragazzi più o meno mi vedete sempre nei
video e mi vedete seduto perché io al
video li faccio da seduto se mi alzo in
piedi incredibile attenzione notizia
incredibile sonno più alto non ci
credete
l'antica roba mica ragazzi le gambe che
cazzo di invenzione cosa pensano
chiamata in giro con la sedia
[Musica]
favi risponde fa mi fai apparire leasys
nel video posto roberto brenner steve
diresti mai in piscina vestito per
vedere la reazione della gente allora
ragazzi che ci crediate o no l'ho fatto
davvero ma lo metto nel prossimo vlog
perché esageratamente strana ma troppo
forza prima di concludere ragazzine che
posso passare uno scarto di un pacchetto
che da un casino di tempo che non lo
faccio pagare l'occasione di tempo che
non ho una paura tremenda nel farlo non
la più pallida idea di che cazzo possa
trovare dentro ma ho una paura tremenda
che capisce che non è facile che cazzo
allora sentite per l'amor di dio che
cosa dovrebbe mai essere questa cosa ma
perché
ma perché obiettivo ho vinto ho vinto e
la golden card ha trovato la grande
giorno amici credo o tra troppo b card
cosa occorre no vabbè dai posso
fottutamente incontrare me stesso se è
[ __ ] e tra alma do sono il mio kissi ma
se vuoi incontrare fa vj dal vivo ok ok
spedisco sta cosa che conta nome domani
incontrare fa vj giu roma c'erano
ragazzi detto questo possiamo affari
domanda io non ci sto ancora no allora
non è possibile
porca [ __ ] prima di concludere ragazzi
possono fare domanda è la fabi domanda
di oggi è viva se tipo prova a darla una
persona a caso e prosa la trova lì sad
eyes alto davanti a chiunque essa sia e
dedicò il vinto la giornata non fa vj e
voglio vedere la reaction non so se vi
va che io faccia cosa perché mi vergogno
abbastanza fatemelo sapere così almeno
non faccio cagate per niente sempre
belle le fa vi domande ci provo mi danno
soddisfazione proprio tanto luca ragazzi
conclude l'episodio spero che il video
vi sia piaciuto per ogni mi piace che
mettete un ventilatore per me perché
porca [ __ ] sto morendo di caldo ma
giuro troppo esplodo da me tanto c'è un
giubbotto antiproiettile e quindi
ragazzi servizio è piaciuto assente al
momento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come noi video tratta
descrizione sono riusciti sia tra i 20
euro dai ragazzi
[Musica]